- Three, two, one.
Ahh!
(light upbeat music)
- So I guess we've been friends for what
a little bit over a year.
- I think we click because
we're total opposites.
- We are very opposite.
I'm the most anxious
person that I know of,
and I don't consider you
to be an anxious person.
- Right, I wear overalls to shoots.
- I'd say we have a pretty
similar sense of humor.
What is this?
Where's the other?
- It's in the back.
- Okay, sure.
- That's called style.
- Style.
We are going to the Premier57 Spa,
and we're gonna go to some saunas.
We're gonna go to some steam rooms.
- [Lorena] And we're gonna get naked.
- [Anita] I haven't been to a spa.
- I've never been to a spa
so this is huge for me.
(sneeze)
- That's how I react to nudity.
I'm allergic to it.
I just wanna be more
comfortable with my body,
and I'd like to think that by being naked
suddenly I'm just gonna
be really comfortable.
- I'm excited though.
I'm excited to go to a spa with you.
Challenge our friendship.
Best friendship.
- Are you ready to go to the spa?
- I'm ready!
- I'm scared.
So we got there at 8:00 am.
We put on some very lovely
comfortable robes and slippers.
- [Lorena] Very swanky.
- Oh and they gave us water.
- Free water.
- The moment someone
gives me non-tap water
I'm very impressed.
- We went to Sauna Valley.
There are a number of different saunas
for anyone that likes anything.
- [Lorena] My favorite sauna
was the color therapy room.
That was just like a music
video, and just like...
- It's a never ending photoshoot.
I really liked the Himalayan Salt sauna.
- Wow that is warm.
Woah that feels nice.
- I also really liked
the Igloo Room, which...
- I did not like.
- I liked that I felt like I
was inside of a refrigerator,
and I always wonder
what it's like in there.
Cause I like to eat.
- That is such a weird...
- [Anita] So we went to
the Hydrotherapy Pool
after some sangria just to loosen me up.
We pressed a bunch of buttons.
A bunch of jets came out.
- Are you feeling ready to get naked?
- Uhh.
Now I'm ready.
- Why are you just not changing?
- I am changing.
- You look like Dracula.
You pitched this.
- I did.
I did pitch this but
I'm suddenly remembering
what I agreed to do.
How can she be so chill?
What if there's something
wrong with my body?
We went to the Water Lounge.
Get into these showers
where you rinse off.
When we we're showering
and then we're both going
"okay, when are you coming out?
"You coming out now?"
That was the moment I
was like I could leave.
I'm very scared.
- We're gonna examine each
others bodies like doctors.
- I don't wanna examine anything.
- Well I felt calm about it.
I think like right before
we did it I was like oh,
but I also do think that
I can only imagine how you we're feeling,
and if I felt like a tinge of it
you must have been feeling
that times a hundred.
- [Anita] It definitely
wasn't as scary as I thought.
- I feel okay.
- I feel okay mostly
because I have this camera
so I have somewhere to look right now.
I learned that all bodies
essentially all have the same parts.
- Well if you didn't know that
before I would be concerned.
- Yeah, I felt a lot more comfortable
once we got in the hot tub.
- You we're essentially
excited for any parts
that helped you censor your body.
- We're naked.
It's not terrible.
- I like it.
- Maybe we should go dance naked.
- Yeah, let's go do it.
And then we danced.
- Oh we danced.
It is super fun to dance naked,
which I never got to
do with anyone almost.
- Almost?
- Well I mean...
- I've never been able to say that.
- In my mind I felt spas we're for like
bachelorette parties and
your significant other.
- Yeah.
- Turns out you can go with your friends.
I would do it again.
- I would do it again.
I mean the spa was really nice.
It was really relaxing.
Yeah, we felt bougie
but like in a good way.
- I got naked today.
I didn't chicken out
which is honestly something
I was worried about.
- I just think everyone is beautiful,
and I really appreciate
everyone for who they are
externally, internally,
and it was just like access
to each other in a way
that was more vulnerable and intimate.
(upbeat music)